el minimalismo japonés se instaló esta
tarde aquí en el festival de cannes como
parte de la competencia internacional se
presentó drive my car del japonés
ryusuke taguchi una película basada en
el libro del nobel de literatura-
murakami que cuenta la historia y el
encuentro entre dos personas
aparentemente muy diferentes un director
de teatro y actor la chica que le hace
de chófer cuando él realiza una
residencia en hiroshima en el sur del
país durante las largas horas que pasan
en el coche ambos se dan cuenta que
tienen una deuda con el pasado y que se
van a ayudar mutuamente para superar sus
traumas y si no hoy fue la conferencia
de prensa de la película el día de la
bandera del actor y realizador
estadounidense jumper en esta
conferencia de prensa el actor se dio
tiempo para criticar la gestión del
cómic 19 que hizo el ex presidente de
donald trump dijo que fue obscena
política y humanamente y que fue como si
una persona con su metralleta disparara
contra los más vulnerables desde una
torre en la casa blanca